buenas tardes karen lópez ha ratificado
ante el parlamento peruano la denuncia
que hizo ante la fiscalía y no solamente
eso también ha ofrecido proporcionar una
nómina de congresistas y empresarios que
estarían inmersos en actos ilícitos con
el gobierno del presidente pedro
castillo y señala que tendrían mayor
información para proporcionar las
denuncias de lópez son graves porque
deja en un mal momento al presidente
pedro casi o le resta credibilidad
cuando él pretende modificar la
constitución política peruana y tal como
señala en diversos analistas políticos
las denuncias de karen y lópez pone en
la cabeza de pedro castillo en bandeja
de plata de los rivales políticos que
pretenden retirarlo de la presidencia
karelin lópez es una empresaria que está
siendo investigada por la fiscalía
peruana por sostener reuniones
clandestinas que supuestamente servirían
para organizar con el presidente pedro
castillo el otorgamiento de licitaciones
de obras públicas francisco hablemos
ahora de otro tema que mantiene
tensionado al país el gobierno peruano
declaró el estado de emergencia en las
localidades cerca a la gran mina las
bambas que es la productora del 2 por
ciento del cobre mundial esto por una
protesta de comuneros verdad contanos
qué repercusiones tiene esta situación
hasta el momento
en medio del estado de emergencia en
mirar las bambas el gobierno ha enviado
un contingente de más de 800 policías
para tratar de desalojar a los comuneros
que desde hace más de 13 días han tomado
el control del mayor centro de
producción de cobre del perú hasta el
momento se vienen registrando tres
heridos los indígenas señalan que la
protesta se debe porque la empresa
minera habría incumplido compromisos
asumidos por ellos por toda esta ola de
protestas bloqueo de carreteras que se
producen en esa región el perú ha dejado
de exportar concentrados de cobre por el
valor de 110 millones de dólares señalan
diversos expertos y no solamente eso
también el estado peruano ha dejado de
percibir alrededor de 16 millones de
dólares por el concepto de regalías y
canon minero esta es una situación muy
difícil para el perú en momentos en que
el país trata de restablecer su economía
que fue duramente impactada por la
pandemia del 19